hey everyone diabolo here and in today's
video i'm going to go over all of the
breathing styles throughout the entire
demon slayer series so firstly breathing
forms are swordsmanship stars throughout
the demon slayer world that make use of
an esoteric breathing technique known as
total concentration breathing if unsure
an esoteric technique or just a meaning
in general is simply one intended for or
likely to be understood by only a small
number of people will they specialize
knowledge or interest which to put it
plain and simply is exactly what happens
throughout the entire story and even
inside of the demon's day headquarters
with countless numbers of unnamed
slayers who never even achieved the
first step in unlocking their own
breathing style but if you do make it
past this first strength barrier all
known breathing styles currently taught
within the demonstrate core are derived
from sun breathing this is just due to
the fact that the first person who
discovered and brought breathing styles
to the slayers yarichi was unable to
teach any of them his sun breathing
forms so to work around this he played
to each person's strength and taught
them a modified breathing system this is
where we are introduced to all of the
current breathing forms that we see
throughout the entire story but firstly
sun breathing or as we come to know it
through tangiero's version the hinokami
kagura is a breathing style only known
and taught by the kamado family there
are 12 individual forms of this
technique that we learn over time but
massive spoiler i guess in reality or
technically however you want to look at
it there is only actually one form made
up of 12 different techniques that when
all connected together complete the
original attack or form that yorici had
intended in the first place before
tanjudo there were three other users of
the style they were tanjoro kamado who's
tangero's dad sumi yoshi who was the
first ancestor of the kamado family to
inherit the sun breathing and obviously
the goat himself yorichi tsukikoni this
next breathing style is a personal
favorite of mine and one of the five
main breathing styles directly derived
from sun breathing flame breathing is a
breathing style that mimics flames and
replicates it within the user's
movements techniques and abilities there
are nine techniques in total within the
style with six known forms among these
the insanely beautiful ninth form ren
goku as an esoteric art exclusively to
the rengoku family most if not all known
techniques and forms involve extremely
powerful singular strikes which burn
their opponents with most attacks being
initiated from above an opponent or by
swinging from above their own head with
their sword when it comes to the known
users kyojiro along with his father are
the only people that we see using this
breathing technique but prior to
creating her own form called love
breathing matsuri also used flame
breathing sticking with mitsuri and her
love breathing it is a style as i said
before made by altering the flame
breathing she learned from kyogre to
suit her specific needs it takes
advantage of her body's unique muscle
density which grants her inhuman
strength without making her physically
bulky in turn this allows her to deliver
fast and powerful blows while moving
with her incredible flexibility and
agility love breathing has six forms at
a minimum with five known techniques
revealed throughout the battles that we
see as love breathing relies on her
body's special muscle density it is a
style that only she can use and from
there it can also be assumed that this
breathing star requires her whip like
katana to use as well to its utmost
ability at least another of the five
main breathing styles originally taught
to members of the daemon slayer corps is
that of the thunder breathing which like
the name somewhat suggests it is a
breathing style that copies lightning
more directly the swift strikes and
instantaneous flashes corresponding to
lightning ripping through the sky users
also mimic lightning when building up to
perform techniques as they can cause the
air to vibrate and create immensely loud
sounds just like thunder with each step
that they take
thunder breathing has six standard forms
in total with the first form said to be
the foundation for all the other forms
however zinetsu developed his own
seventh form called the honokazuchi
nokami which was in order to stand on
equal ground and fight alongside kaigaku
his former senior disciple under gigoro
those three are also the only known
users of thunder breathing that were
introduced throughout the story
most if not all of the known techniques
and forms involve utilizing building up
speeds and immensely fast attacks to
overwhelm the enemy instantly users of
thunder breathing also visualize
themselves seemingly creating and trying
to manipulate lightning and electricity
when unleashing techniques just like
flame breathing thunder also has an
offshoot which lead directly to the
creation of another breathing style this
here is the fantastically explosive
sound breathing most of if not all of
the known techniques and forms of which
there are five at a minimum utilize
explosives to deal massive amounts of
damage while making use of extremely
fast movements as well as the user's
sense of hearing the only known user of
the style tenkin uzui uses a style
developed using his superhuman sense of
hearing called the musical score
technique which involves tengen reading
his opponent's motions and
deconstructing them into sound by
analyzing the rhythm of their movements
through this he is able to read them
like a sheet of musical paper to take
advantage of the openings to a much
greater effect like matsuri as well
tengen also created his own style so it
can be assumed that his breathing forms
are only able to be used with his two
massive cleavers so next up in the
family tree of breathing forms is the
moon breathing which like its creator
michikatu tukukuni is one of the most
overbearing and intense styles
throughout the story this is due to the
fact that michikatsu is the twin brother
of the originator of breathing forms in
the first place yorichi however just
like everyone else that was taught by
yorichi he was unable to ever learn sun
breathing and in turn trained in an
alternative breathing style which later
became moon breathing this breathing
style is only used by the upper ranked
one kokushibo previously known as
obviously michikatsu once he did become
a demon though he improved his breathing
style using his blood demon art which he
used to create dozens of controllable
crescent moons from his swords making
this breathing style one of if not the
most powerful and deadly one ever shown
as kokushibo lived for centuries
continuously improving his moon
breathing style he eventually developed
at least 16 different techniques by the
time of the infinity castle arc pretty
much all of the forms seen are varied
swordsmanship techniques that focus on
swift and powerful strikes they always
follow the shape and pattern of a
crescent moon because of this breathing
style's great amount of variation and
techniques this form has a great blend
of offensive and defensive capabilities
similar to sun breathing moving on we
come to another of the five original
forms which is the most common breathing
style among demon slayers due to it
being the easiest to learn for beginners
this is the water breathing which like
the other styles mimics the elements
named after it with water breathing it's
more the flow flexibility and
adaptability of the liquid that the
slayer will try and adapt into their
sword play water breathing has 10
techniques with an 11th one created and
exclusively used by the current water
hashira giyutomioka
along with numerous modified versions of
pre-existing forms
pretty much all of the techniques
require the user bending their body arm
and weapon in a fluid motion to match
the movements of rushing or flowing
water users also visualize themselves
seemingly creating and manipulating
water when unleashing its techniques
because it's the most common style there
have been a bunch of people who have
been said to use it or that we've seen
use it they include tsukonji along with
his trainees giyu tanjiro and murata
however maratha's water form is like
literally so weak that it's only ever
mentioned once in a little like section
of text before a chapter i can't even
remember like exactly where i saw it i
just know that i have seen it a hundred
percent
and finally obviously the deceased
members that soconji had trained sabiso
and makomo along with countless unnamed
trainees due to water breathing being
the most common this has led to it
having the most offshoots or derivatives
the first of these is aguero open eyes
serpent breathing since this technique
is currently known to be only utilized
by obanite it is thought that the user's
snake-like blade is imperative for this
technique to work in a similar way to
the other hashera who have created their
own breathing styles serpent breathing
has five known techniques and forms all
of which are shown throughout the story
each of these forms focus on twisting
and bending the sword just like how a
serpent would slither its way through
things the attacks are not direct and
constantly meander which can ultimately
let the attacker strike anywhere in a
confusing and frightening manner the
next breathing form derived from water
breathing is that of flower breathing
this interesting yet barely known
breathing style is only ever used by two
individuals both being a generation
apart there's been the elder sister of
shinobu kane kocho and kano man i always
struggle with their names i don't know
why i struggle with names in general but
men always struggle with their names for
some reason unlike other derived
abilities it is not necessary to have a
specific type of weapon to fight with
flower breathing there are at least
seven different techniques including the
flower breathing final form all of which
are graceful attacks that solely focus
on agility over pure strength this style
also enhances and utilizes one's vision
albeit at the possible cost of the
eyesight as revealed in kano's battle
against the upper rank too when it comes
to shinobu kocho she most likely trained
to learn this form early on but due to
her extremely petite body structure she
had to come up with an alternative which
turned out to be her prolific insect
breathing the swordplay can only be
utilized by her and only using a unique
katana with a needle-like tip resembling
an insect stinger in appearance and in
function the stinger is exactly designed
for an injection of wisteria poison into
a demon and insect breathing has four
known techniques and forms however they
were never specifically numbered so it's
hard to gauge how many more techniques
she might have cultivated exactly but
all the known forms include stabbing
thrusting and making shallow cuts with
her needle sword to inflict multiple
wounds in order to inject various
amounts of lethal wisteria-based poisons
into them so this next breathing form is
another personal favorite of mine just
due to the fact that sunimi shinozugawa
is its current user and that it also
resembles a real-life japanese
swordsmanship style called the jigen ryu
which uh probably got that wrong which
like when breathing is a sword welding
style that emphasizes on the first
strike and high stances if confused
because i've seen high stances i think
once before high stances are like mobile
stances that allow one to reposition
rapidly whereas low stances are very
powerful and assist delivery of power
through the body to either the arms or
the legs so if someone bends their legs
pretty much when they're performing any
breathing form it's a low stance and
vice versa for a high stance with wind
breathing there are at least nine
techniques with all of them being seen
throughout the final battles against
kokoshibo and muzan they all involve
purely offensive attacks most of which
utilize rotating movements to generate
swift whirlwind light slashes that
greatly increase the welder's striking
range or utilizing the air around them
to deliver sharp sickle-like shaped
attacks the only known or previously
mentioned wind breathers was sanemi's
old best friend masachika kumino who was
the actual reason for sunimi even
becoming a demonstrator corps member in
the first place but i guess that's
another story for another day next up in
one of two offshoots of wind breathing
is the complete nut case of a character
inosuka hushy bearer's own beast
breathing style that he personally
created and worked on after having to
live in the mountains and fight for
survival so because of this it can be
assumed that like others it can only be
utilized by someone with dual nature and
katanas and an extremely acute sense of
touch so pretty much only an oscar but
obviously i shouldn't even be saying
this form when it comes to the beast
himself as unlike other breathing
techniques only supplement moves are
called forms whereas assaulting beast
breathing moves are called fangs instead
like for example inosuke's fourth fang
slice and dice has him deliver multiple
diagonal double slashes with both swords
making it an assaulting move compared to
his eighth form explosive rush where he
just charges towards his opponent at
blinding speeds while swinging both of
his swords all over the place because of
this almost randomness and his abilities
of which there are at least 10 different
forms people seem to think that all of
his attacks will be simple and
straightforward you are pretty much
always caught off guard by his
animalistic movements and insane
unpredictability the last breathing
style or form derived from wind is that
of muchero toquitos and what i assume to
be his own developed missed breathing
style this is not due to his weapon
being any different exactly but more or
less the clothes that he wears during
battle that helps to obscure him from
the enemy's line of sight misbreathing
is a style that imitates mist trying to
obscure the user's movements and
techniques from the enemy there are a
total of seven known different forms and
techniques all of which involve swift
strikes and movements performed in a
unique pattern that obscures the
opponent's senses and surroundings as if
the battlefield were enveloped and
missed as i said earlier i think this is
mature's own developed breathing style
but there very much may have been a
predecessor as it has never hinted at
him previously using wind breathing
anywhere that i could find prior to him
using missed breathing when it comes to
the final of the five main breathing
styles and the final breathing style in
general derived from yodorichi sun
breathing we have gyome's version of the
stone breathing i only see his version
for the fact that he uses a giant flail
connected by chain to an axe and during
kokushibo's flashback an ancestor of
stone breathing is seen wielding a giant
kusarigama-like weapon so it could be
possible that each of the stoneheshira
in the past have had a slightly
different version to work and pair with
their weapon just like how other slaves
have been seen to do so when creating
their own techniques stone breathing has
at least five different forms with all
of them being seen throughout the story
these techniques all utilize their
ground beneath the user and the vast
surroundings to generate powerful and
sturdy attacks that specialize in both
offense and defensive capabilities and
to wrap the video up guys i think stone
breathing out of all the other forms
probably is the third strongest just
below moon breathing being the second
strongest and then sun breathing
obviously being the strongest of them
all for the fact that it's the
originator's form and the original form
in general so you can't really get much
stronger than that i would assume yo
what up
thanks for
sticking to the end of the video if you
guys have managed to stick to the very
end of this demon slayer breathing
performance video obviously i'm puffed
as right now i tried climbing a
tree over there i don't know if i've put
any of the editing in to record it at
the top of the tree i wish it was a
little bit more like tangier and had the
ability to be able to just jump up a
tree or something
like that with like a water breathing
jump form but
i don't i'm too poor so obviously if you
guys have enjoyed the video and want to
see more stuff like this from like
obviously juicy carson and demonstrate
for like the breathing forms your innate
abilities explained but make sure you
let me know down in the comment section
below so i can uh do them all in the
next up and coming videos i hope you
guys like where i am in the middle of
absolutely
nowhere in a forest with a bird chilling
on a tree over there
yeah whatever and that dickie with a
chainsaw from the last video still over
there i only moved 10 meters away from
where i last was but obviously if you
guys have enjoyed the video then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
if you are new around here actually
own a reverse card then hit that
like button as well but for now open
your professional degenerate diavolo and
i'll see you all in a bit bye
[Music]
you